Hey, this is Brian from Fullstack Egg.
Today I want to show you something called Paperless N G X.
Paperless N G X is an open
source digital archive for your documents.
Think of all the paper that piles up around a farm, leases,
crop insurance, equipment
records, notes from the shop, paper list gives all that a
single home.
So I have a little note here that started as a piece of
paper.
I'm just going to drop the photo into Paperless, it uploads
it, files away the original, and
then it tries to read the text on the page with OCR, which
is optical character recognition.
And that's the big first one.
The document is not just a picture and a folder anymore.
Paperless knows the date, it can store tags and the
document type, and most importantly
you can now search the text that it found.
So later on if I remember something about a hydraulic hose,
but not where I put the
note, I can search for that phrase and pull it right back
up.
And that's the basic paperless workflow.
You capture the document once and you can stop hunting for
it.
In another video I'm going to show you what we did with
Paperless Egg that adds AI to
make searching even smarter.
That's it for this one, thanks for watching.